bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo
anterior les mostré que si aplicamos una
fuerza a cierta masa digamos m entonces
si aplicamos una fuerza efe a una masa m
digamos a un objeto de masa m que está
en el reposo y si esto se desplazaba
digamos una distancia de tenemos un
desplazamiento de entonces podríamos
decir que fuerza por distancia fuerza
por distancia es igual a la mitad aún oa
un medio de la masa por la velocidad al
cuadrado donde la velocidad es
justamente la velocidad que obtiene este
cuerpo cuando llega a este punto muy
bien entonces esto era lo que vimos en
el vídeo anterior y de hecho definimos
esta parte de aquí de la izquierda como
el trabajo trabajo y de hecho lo denota
vamos con una w el trabajo lo denota
vamos de esta forma y lo que teníamos
del lado derecho que es la mitad de la
masa por la velocidad al cuadrado es
justamente la energía cinética muy bien
la energía cinética y e incluso aquí tú
puedes ver la relación que hay entre
trabajo y energía verdad y entonces la
energía es la energía cinética es
justamente la que necesitas aplicar para
mover este objeto de masa m a su
velocidad actual después de un
desplazamiento de muy bien es justamente
lo que nos está diciendo la energía
cinética entonces por ejemplo si esté
aquí tiene cierta velocidad ve y
entonces podemos calcular aquí la
energía cinética justo como un medio de
la masa por la velocidad al cuadrado muy
bien ahora lo mejor puede que te esté
confundiendo digamos todas estas letras
y demás pero pero no no hay ningún
problema digamos que esta masa es de 5
kilogramos y que nuestra velocidad es d
metros sobre segundo ok entonces si
tenemos esto fácilmente uno puede
calcular la energía cinética como un
medio por la masa que en este caso es
cinco kilogramos cinco kilogramos por la
velocidad la velocidad que son siete
metros sobre segundo muy bien y esto hay
que elevarlo al cuadrado verdad entonces
qué es lo que vamos a tener tenemos
siete por cinco más bien 7 por 7 son 49
digamos que a groso modo son 50 verdad y
si dividimos entre 2 son 25 por 5 nos da
aproximadamente 125 kilogramos metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado por otro metro
que esos son newtons por metro y que
estos son justamente 125 jules
y entonces si no sabemos realmente cuál
fue la fuerza que aplicamos a esta masa
simplemente basta calcular la energía
cinética que es la cantidad de energía
que tenemos que aplicarle a ese cuerpo
para llegar a dicha velocidad ok vamos a
hacer ahora otro ejemplo que no sea
horizontal digamos que tengo ahora una
masa m igual
no sé tengo aquí una masa m pero ahora
le estamos aplicando una fuerza que sea
vertical aunque digamos tenemos una
fuerza aquí no sé podríamos pensar a lo
mejor que esta es la fuerza
digamos que sea igual a la fuerza de
gravedad ok que sería masa por la
aceleración debida a la gravedad y
digamos que aplicamos esta fuerza
durante digamos por una un
desplazamiento o por una altura h ahora
lo estamos haciendo de forma vertical
verdad entonces lo que nos dice es que
bueno si si queremos calcular el trabajo
tenemos que calcular la fuerza que en
este caso sería fuerza por la distancia
la distancia esto quién sería pues
nuestra fuerza en este caso es masa por
la aceleración debida a la gravedad y
nuestro desplazamiento ahora es h ok
entonces aquí tenemos justamente no es
trabajo y a lo mejor tú puedes decir oye
yo porque querría levantar un objeto de
masa m a cierta altura h y es que si
ocurre en la vida cotidiana por ejemplo
piensa en un elevador piensa que tienes
aquí un elevador no sé que quizás haya
una persona y que ya en conjunto tengan
una masa de 10 kilogramos muy bien
suponte que a lo mejor pues está atado a
alguna cuerda con el cual puede moverse
hacia arriba o hacia abajo y nosotros
sabemos que este leve elevador está
sujeto a la fuerza de gravedad verdad a
la fuerza de gravedad
entonces el detalle es que nosotros
queremos subir este elevador digamos 100
metros
no sé tal vez queremos subirlo 100
metros ok vamos a hacer esto más
derechito digamos que queremos subir
esto
metros ok ahora bien si nosotros
suponemos que estamos levantando este
elevador de velocidad constante es decir
que esto no acelera eso es importante
verdad porque por las leyes de newton
sabemos que si no hay una aceleración
entonces la fuerza neta en este en este
elevador es cero quiere decir que la
fuerza que aplicamos hacia arriba para
subir el elevador debe ser exactamente
igual que la fuerza de gravedad para que
no cambie su velocidad constante verdad
que si hubiera una o más bien si hubiera
una aceleración hacia arriba quiere
decir que la fuerza que estamos
aplicando para jalar el elevador es
mayor que la de la gravedad o bien si
está desacelerando quiere decir que esa
fuerza es más chica que la fuerza de
gravedad ok entonces en este caso como
podemos calcular esta está
digamos este trabajo que estamos
realizando pues simplemente la fuerza es
la misma que la de la gravedad que
serían 10 kilos 10 kilogramos por la
aceleración debida a la gravedad que
vamos a suponer que es d
que es de 10 no es en realidad que la
gente 9.81 vamos a suponer que son 10
para hacer las cuentas fáciles metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y ahora
multiplicamos por nuestra altura la
altura son
metros entonces aquí tenemos 10 por 10
son
bueno vamos a vamos a hacerlo bien para
que no haya ningún problema
vamos a poner aquí que si se a 9.8 vamos
a decir que es redondeado 9.8 entonces
que es lo que tenemos tenemos 10 por 9.8
son 98 por 100
eso nos da no el 98% son nueve mil
ochocientos jules verdad aquí tenemos
jules
jules muy bien entonces todo este
trabajo no nos lleva a una pregunta a
dónde fue todo ese trabajo o toda esa
energía que utilizamos para subir el
elevador 100 metros y la respuesta es
que se transfirió a la energía potencial
y tú te estarás preguntando oye pero qué
es la energía potencial y la energía
potencial es justamente esto si nos
damos cuenta aquí es fuerza por
distancia que es cierto tipo de energía
verdad es un trabajo y esto que está
escrito aquí es justamente la energía
potencial que en este caso corresponde a
la energía potencial debida a la
gravedad qué quiere decir eso imagínate
que justamente tuvimos nuestro cuerpo
que subimos cierta altura digamos que en
este caso eran 100 metros entonces
cuando lo tenemos en este punto si no
hacemos nada con este objeto sólo le
queda la fuerza de gravedad para perdón
que actúe sobre él si no hay fuerzas
quiere decir que éste empezará a
acelerar hacia abajo debido a la
gravedad
lo que pasó fue que la energía cinética
se convirtió en energía potencial para
que después puedes trabajar
debido a la fuerza de gravedad vamos a
hacer un ejemplo para que sea todo esto
mucho más concreto digamos que tenemos
una masa digamos aquí de un kilogramo
para que sea algo sencillo y digamos que
está suspendido a 10 metros que digamos
aquí está el suelo y estos son 10 metros
muy bien entonces nosotros sabemos que
la energía potencial la energía
potencial es la masa es vamos a copiarlo
es masa por la aceleración debido a la
gravedad por la altura la altura verdad
en este caso que es lo que tenemos
tenemos un kilo un kilogramo verdad por
la gravedad que llevamos vamos a ver a
dejarlo como 10 justo para para que sea
más más sencillo 10 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado por nuestra altura que son
10 metros que esto es un aproximado
verdad y esto que son esto es
aproximadamente 1 por 10 por 10 son
100 newtons verdad kilogramo metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado esto de aquí
nos da un newton y luego aquí nos dan
metros así que tenemos 100 jules 100
jules verdad esto es lo que tenemos como
energía potencial es decir la energía
que se requiere para llevar de un objeto
que está digamos en el suelo este mismo
objeto exista en el suelo es la energía
que necesitamos para llevarla a esta
altura verdad eso es lo que es la
energía potencial y entonces uno podría
utilizar fórmulas cinemáticas para ver
cuál sería la velocidad final cuando uno
deja caer este digamos este bloque citó
pero lo que vamos a utilizar y parte
para hacerlo mucho más rápido es la ley
de la conservación de la energía y aquí
es en donde resulta muy útil todo esto
del trabajo y la energía y demás lo que
nos dice la ley de la conservación de la
energía es que la energía no se crea o
se destruye sólo se transforma en alguna
otra forma de energía y hay que tener
cierto cuidado con este
pero esencialmente si nosotros teníamos
digamos a esta altura que la energía
potencial era 100 entonces cuando ya a
bajar a cuando tenemos una altura cero
la energía potencial pues justamente
cero grados y la altura es cero todo
esto vale cero qué pasó
teníamos una energía que pasó de 100 a 0
dónde quedó la energía si si no se
destruye digamos entonces tú dirás qué
pasó y puedes decirlo adivinando porque
aunque aquí la energía potencial es cero
en realidad lo que ocurre con él con el
bloque es que cuando ya cayó viene a una
velocidad muy muy rápida
así que puedes ir pensando qué es lo que
ocurre con este bloque pero lo veremos
en el próximo vídeo